smile dream kardashian may have just
turned 3 today but in true Kardashian
fashion the birthday girl enjoyed the
celebration all weekend long Kim
Kardashian shared these adorable pics on
Instagram sub brother Rob's baby girl
dream celebrating with her cousins true
Thompson some and Chicago West at her
trolls themed birthday party
so we're welding it's a lot of little
people so I love it though I loved every
second of it it's such a blessing and
dreams dad seemingly making a small
appearance in the background we see you
Rob Rob is honestly the best dad he
reminds me so much of my dad and how
attentive and fun and loving he is with
her today Rob wished his daughter a
happy birthday on Instagram with these
new photos of dream casually on a
helicopter ride talk about toddler
Cole's family is super important to me
so obviously I want my baby to have a
good relationship with my mom and my
sisters just like my dad instilled in us
so I can have those memories and just
have a happy life the 32 year old has
recently been showing up at more family
events et learned that he attended his
sister Kendall Jenner's early birthday
Halloween bash and she was also spotted
looking noticeably slimmer celebrating
Kim's recent 39th birthday you know he's
such a good man and such a sweetheart
and he's got a good fine spirit and a
lot of faith so you know I put my my put
my money on Rob I just he's such a good
good person last week a source told et
Rob's main focus has always been his
daughter and that was the main reason he
wanted to get healthy the family is
happy to see Rob happy and have him
around for major events and holidays Rob
is in a very good place and this is only
the beginning of his transition
[Music]